we've been graphing arcs on the argan
diagram of the complex plane
and we've come to this particular
example which we did in class
but the way that i graphed it and
obtained the cartesian equation
relied on a lot of visual thinking and
geometric
reasoning now a lot of people feel
uncomfortable with that because it feels
a bit like guesswork and that you have
to do
a fair bit of it through insight and if
someone hadn't shown you how to do that
you wouldn't be sure how to do it
so i'm going to show you an alternative
method now which is to rely on a lot
more algebra i will point out
you will never escape being able to
think about these geometrically because
if you're graphing something you're
going to be drawing you're going to be
on the complex plane
but what i'm going to show you here may
feel like it puts you a bit more at ease
in terms of there is
a um a less hand wavy way to go about it
i'm relying on the algebra you can find
out the points precisely
however i do want to strenuously point
out this is not an ideal way to go about
it you're going to see it's very long
and therefore error prone and so this is
not my recommended
method but it's good to know multiple
ways to get
um to an answer and it's also very
assuring when you can take different
paths and still arrive at the same
solution so
hold on to your hats let's have it go
together the graph arg of
z minus 1 on z plus 1 equals part 4
on an argan diagram all right so the
first thing that we notice
is this is going to be an arc of some
kind
because having this comparison of angles
here if we had pi
on two it'll be a semicircle but it's pi
on four so it's an acute
angle and sorry yeah it's an acute angle
and that gives us
a major arc to remind you of why that is
you just think about
how arcs form angles within
circles if you have a
an obtuse angle a wide angle like this
that necessarily makes the
arc that you're standing on very long
and so the arc that you actually form up
above is going to be very small
and by contrast when you've got when
you've got an angle that's acute like
the one we have in our question
that creates a large arc above you and
that's the one that we draw
and a small arc beneath you which is
kind of the one that is excluded
from the actual subset of the complex
plane so therefore
i already know that i'm going to get a
major arc from this so let's just
note that down major arc and then i also
notice
that i've got these two reference points
here now to make it a little bit clearer
what the reference points are
i'm going to do a couple of things so
firstly i'm going to break apart
remember we're doing this algebraically
i'm going to break apart this a big
argument into two arguments
the argument of a quotient when you're
dividing one complex number
by the other is you subtract the
arguments of each of the individual
complex numbers
so therefore i will subtract arg of z
plus 1.
that equals pi on 4 and then i know it's
really you know arg of
z minus something even though this is
written as a plus i should write it as a
minus to indicate
the actual reference point that i'm
referring to so this one's already fine
i don't need to change it
but then this one here it should be z
take away
negative 1. so these are our two
reference points here one and negative
one and importantly i note the
directions so
one is going to be my start point
negative one is going to be my end point
and i'm going to go anti-clockwise
around the arc to do this because
we measure all arguments angles on the
complex plane
in an anti-clockwise direction okay now
at this point
you really cannot escape doing at least
a rough sketch um so that you guide what
future algebraic working you do because
otherwise there's a whole series of
things that you could do here
that might be helpful or unhelpful
depending on what kind of shape that
you've got
so let's have a rough sketch here you
can see i know
that i'm going from one to negative one
so if i just pop some very rough points
here one and negative one
and i've drawn the um the top half of
the uh complex plane because i know
going anti-clockwise from one to
negative one will send me in this
direction
here so if i were going in the other
direction from negative one
to one then anticlockwise would take me
onto the bottom half
of the complex plane so you've got to
think carefully at where your points are
and what direction you're going in
before you even draw anything
okay now what i'm going to do is i'm
just going to draw a very rough
oopsie does he a very rough arc around
there
it's pretty terrible but all i need is a
rough sense of where's this thing going
so i can start to work out some points
now you can see that it's uh no no need
to find x-intercepts because i already
have them
right the two points have been provided
are both on the real axis so i don't
need to find those
but i immediately noticed that there's
this spot up here which
is obviously like whenever we graph
something we want to know what the
intercepts are
so this is an imaginary intercept it's
on the
y-intercept which is on the imaginary
axis so
how do i find an imaginary intercept
well if i'm finding a y-intercept then
what i usually do is i let
x equal 0. now that is the way that i go
about it but you can see when you have a
look at this question
it is not set up at all to find to let x
equal zero because there aren't even any
x's in the equation
so we need to introduce them to get
toward a cartesian equation which is in
x and y's
and to solve for a point which has an x
and a y
component what i need to do is i need to
say well let's let z
equal x plus i y
doing that let's just substitute in i
get arg of x plus i
y minus one so there's the z
minus one which you can see in the
previous line and then i take away
arg of uh x plus i
y i'm gonna put this back to being plus
one the reason why i put it as minus
negative one
is to make it clearer what the reference
points are but i know where they are now
so i can write it in this simpler form
okay so this is equal to pi on 4.
that's progress at least at least i have
x's and y's now so that when i want to
find the imaginary intercept which i
should write
down i can just substitute in
that there's no real component or that
the real component is zero is a better
way to say it
so to find the imaginary intercept
what i'm going to do is i'm going to let
x equal 0. so what does that give me
i'm going to have arg of i y
minus 1 minus arg
of i y plus 1.
okay so what have i done here you can
see my x's
have just kind of vanished away because
i've substituted zero into them so this
line looks weird but
when i say zero on the end there it's pi
on four this looks weird but it's
it's true and apparently if i solve this
then i'm going to get some
y values which will represent this
y-intercept so
how do i go about that